- I'm gonna reach across.
Hello, aaah! Aaah!
Aaaah! Aaaah!
Put me out now!
Put me out!
Good morning, my name is Rocky Taylor.
I've been a stuntman for 54 years.
I started around 1961.
(whimsical music)
Yes, I'm the oldest
working stuntman, I s'pose.
I was the youngest, now I'm the oldest.
(jazzy music)
Just sort of fell into it.
I could fall about and do
what the actors couldn't do.
I get punched, fall over a chair,
dive and roll all over the ground.
My first stunt job was a
film called The Young Ones
with Sir Cliff Richards.
They gave me a Guinness Record.
I've got it over there.
The oldest still-working
stuntman in England.
The only stuntman to double
for two Bonds in one year,
Roger Moore.
- The name is Bond.
- [Rocky] And Sean Connery.
- James Bond.
(grunting)
- My last film was this Sunday.
I was working on a
little car chase sequence
around Trafalgar Square, which was great.
I mean, I've been in it
for so many years now,
and I can't think of
anything else I could do.
(dramatic music)
I had a very bad accident on Death Wish 3.
I nearly got killed.
This is the shot of me
doing the fall which nearly took my life.
(explosions)
Well, they blew it up
before I got to the edge.
I run through the flames,
put my hands up over my eyes,
came through, broke my back, pelvis.
Thank God I survived.
I don't know how I survived.
But you're gonna get a little
knock and a little bruise.
Best part of the job.
Why do I keep doing it?
I've had a great life.
I've been 'round the world twice.
I've met all the stars.
I love it.
There's nothing else about it.